I'm Jeff hennig I'm professor of
political sign
at Teachers College at Columbia and I'll
be serving as
cilla tater for this meeting which
basically means introducing our
panelists and then helping with the
question and answers at the end we've
got a panel here with two presenters who
will be presenting as a team Jennifer
Bell Ellwanger has served new york city
public schools for more than 15 25 years
15 years yeah I'm sorry put it my mother
started as a kindergartener and
currently leads the research and policy
support group at the department as its
executive director that groups prime is
the primary source of research and
analytics to inform system-wide policy
decision making miss belt Ellwanger is
also senior advisor to the Chancellor
and serves as a special representatives
to the State Education Department to
improve alignment between the city's
reform efforts and those at the state
and federal level she began as a
elementary classroom teacher and then an
administrator in community district 11
in bronx new york and holds a position
now as an adjunct faculty member at
Fordham University School of Education
the other half of the team is Katherine
Rohan joined the New York City
Department of Education in May of 2010
where she serves as the director of
research and evaluation in the research
and policy support group she oversees
the design and implement
both internal and external program
evaluations and also serves on the
Department of Education institutional
review board for protection of human
subjects and manages the department's
qualification process for external
evaluation services prior to coming to
the Department of Education she was a
consultant at the gluten in research
group in Cambridge Massachusetts to
choose shields a PhD in Experimental
Psychology with a focus on mental health
they've got a presentation that as I
said they'll work on together and I
think the best way to do this would be
to have them work through the
presentation and then loud plenty of
time for discussion and questions
afterwards good afternoon thank you Jeff
I was going to say the same thing that
we're going to go through the
presentation for all of you if you have
if you have questions that are relevant
for clarification please do stop us in
the midst of the presentation otherwise
we hope with Jeff's health to work
through for work through discussion
questions and conversations at the end
of the presentation so good afternoon
everyone today we're going to talk to
you and provide you with some
information about the New York City
Department of Education accountability
tools and how we support how we support
schools in using those tools both for
accountability purposes but more
importantly to drive student academic
achievement and for instructional
purposes so I have many of my colleagues
here in in the audience today so I think
it will be great to hear from them at
the end with some of their experiences
with regard to many of the tools that
we'll be talking about this afternoon so
for many of you may have heard this in
some of our
discussions this morning we're New York
City deal do e is short for the
Department of Education staff have
presented but children first reform
which is what the New York City
Department of Education has been has
endeavored since 2003 is built on three
pillars and those are leadership
empowerment and accountability and
through those and through those through
that circle that's how we both drive
performance drive data into the schools
and how we help our leaders both
understand student academic achievement
to progress how to make that progress
more accelerated but also then in turn
help schools with how to be accountable
for for those achievement outcomes we
hope and expect that our children first
reforms deliver and produce results what
we use to ensure that we are meeting the
goals that we've set forth are through
two primary measures our high school
graduation rates and our post secondary
outcomes for us with students graduating
on time from high school within four
years and then going on to academic
success and achievement are the primary
goals of our department it doesn't stop
at 12th grade we want to make sure that
they are successful when they go on to
post-secondary careers and a cadet and
academics of course there are many
benchmarks along the way and through the
accountability tools that will share
with you today you'll see many of those
benchmarks driven within the different
accountability tools we work through
three of three main words as we go on
through the accountability process and
our tools it's to evaluate enforce and
enables through the evaluation will go
into before
casinos for a good part of our
discussion today on our accountability
measures which include things you may
have heard about them before a progress
report quality reviews school surveys
and also our federal and state
evaluation system and all of those
measures help schools understand where
they are where they need to go and where
they're where they're struggling and
where they are successful both with
their students and as a school with its
students of all subgroups and where they
are successful as a hole through the
through those evaluation measures we
then in force through consequences and
consequences are both positive and some
are going to be folks would consider to
be more negative and we'll talk about
those a little bit but we really if
you're going to be accountable for for
your results then there should be
consequences in order for it in order
for those measures to be taken seriously
at the school and that the principal and
teacher level finally through these
tools we expect and hope our schools
will enable collaborative inquiry in by
providing all of the data that we're
going to share with you this afternoon
schools are able to come together both
the teacher teams and senior leadership
teens and really take a deep dive in in
the data in the materials that we've
provided to them to understand the
strengths and weaknesses of their
students in all of their special groups
and be able to really dissect that their
achievement and make mid-course
Corrections where needed or plans for
four year long achievement okay so we
went back to the benchmarks our first
benchmark that we want to look at is of
students graduating from high school
within four years from the New York City
Department of Education here we have a
lot of lines in one very long line the
New York City do
has been calculating graduation rates
since 1986 and what we want to show you
here is the progress that we've made
since 2002 2003 when our children first
reforms began if you see if you can look
all the way back here between 1986 and
about 2002 we had very little progress
we hovered at the fifty percent mark
that meant that only fifty percent of
our students were graduating on time
from high school within four years take
a look at at between a 2002 and fast
forward to 2009 you see that the
academic achievement the progress here
of our students able to graduate on time
has accelerated in just in those very
short years we've gone from 51% to
sixty-eight percent of our students
graduating on time and and if we look
backward if we look back we see that
that didn't happen for nearly 20 years
we really hovered at the fifty percent
mark and since 2002 onward the gains
have really jumped and our students are
graduating more frequently on time there
are three lines there and I don't want
to bog everyone down in lots of
different footnotes and things but so
the New York City Department of
Education has been tracking students
high school outcomes since before people
knew how to track high school outcomes
we've had a longitudinal data system
we've been fortunate since 1986 the
state instituted their four-year
calculations of the graduation rate in
2005 and that's the orange triangles
that you see underneath that third line
there that's the state calculated method
it's slightly different and we could
talk about that little bit a little bit
towards the end but even under those
measures measures you see that the that
the city has increased their graduation
rates by nearly twenty-seven percent
since the time that
implemented above those are our green
dots those green dots include August
graduates on beginning in 2008 the state
agreed to include August graduates in
their four-year definition of outcomes
and that's very important for the New
York City Department of Education
because we know and recognize that
students both take longer than four
years we know at least we continue to
calculate graduation rates until fifth
and six years but we also know that many
students need to finish up some
coursework or Regents examination which
is required for for graduation in that
last in that last summer and we see that
if you look at that fifty-nine percent
of June graduates that increases 263
after august another important benchmark
for us is are we seeing students
increasing their enrollment in college
directly out of the new york city public
schools if we are preparing our students
they should be able to enter into they
should be able to enter into college
ready to do the coursework what we have
seen at the City University of New York
tuning which is the New York City
Department of Education counterpart when
we think about public education in New
York City we can see that a steady
increase of our students have been
enrolling at the City University as
first-time freshmen a beginning in 2002
through 2009 and more importantly more
than 6,000 there are more than 6,000
black and Hispanic New York City
students graduating that it entered CUNY
in 2009 compared to those in 2002 and
also what we're we're very carefully
tracking is our remediation rates for
those of you who have been following any
of the New York City or local newspapers
and even the
national conversation has been around
okay so you graduated them they went on
to college what were they ready to do
the academic work needed to be
successful and we have seen a steady
decline in our remediation rates at at
CUNY since 2002 now that being said we
have that's only about fifty percent and
we know that we need to improve that and
get that down and that's the focus of
the coming the coming year and years in
order to make sure that our academic our
academic courses are rigorous in order
to meet the to meet the so that students
are not in need of remediation when they
go on to college so looking at school
accountability in New York City again we
go back to those three e's evaluate and
force and enable and within those three
areas we talked a little bit about that
but in the evaluation which will go into
a minute we're going to highlight
progress reports and quality reviews
also things that we look at around the
evaluation our school surveys which is
one of the largest census surveys in
addition to the census in the united
states on the university of chicago also
does a very large survey but it's on a
sample not the way that New York City
does it so we have 1.1 million students
we have over 800,000 responses from
parents it's amazing we end we have the
federal and state evaluation which that
is from from new york state education
department and they also for in order
for schools to make adequate yearly
progress targets they do also measure
our students our schools and our
students progress we look at me look at
the consequences the outcomes of these
measures we look at rewards if if
schools are successful if school leaders
are successful if teachers are
successful there are monetary bonuses
but there are also consequences for for
consistent failure of
of schools not not getting their
students to make progress in gains and
those can lead to restructuring or
phase-out of chronically failing schools
and that conversation is going on next
door when we're talking about school
turnaround models we really are working
as Jeff indicated part of my role as
State Education Department liaison is to
work through aligning city and state
policies now it's only a little phrase
but you can imagine how difficult that
can be between bringing both of these
organizations together but it's so
important that we align those measures
so that schools are not confused or
conflicted by what one measures saying
against another we are not there yet I
can assure you but we are working
towards that alignment particularly with
race to the top which we'll talk about a
little bit too but we don't want our
schools to be helpless in all this that
this is done to them and add them but
not for them and so we enable schools
with tools that help them meet their
progress we provide them with a suite of
periodic assessments we have hands-on
data training and collective and use of
collaborative teacher teams we have and
I'll highlight for you and many of the
educators here from New York City can
even talk about this our achievement
reporting an innovation system called
eros which is a state-of-the-art data a
student information system and we're
going to showcase that a little bit down
the road here and also through our
errors platform we enable schools to do
knowledge sharing if you think about in
a classroom there's so much knowledge in
a school but it's all in that building
all in that class and what we're trying
to do is get that information shared
with other schools share share share
best practices and we're using that
through our hours platform okay Katie
hi everyone so Jen mentioned the
different types of tools that we provide
our schools with to help them track how
well they're doing and where they can go
from there and to perhaps of the most
comprehensive tools that we think we
have at the moment are the progress
report and the quality worth you so here
is a snapshot of the progress report and
just as there are a million students in
our school system over a million and at
the end of each year they get their
grades on the report card there ABCD or
hopefully not F we feel the need to hold
ourselves accountable as well so each
year starting in 07 the schools received
a grade a similar letter grade of a b c
d or f and as you can see at the top
left here this is a this is a great
school here got their ultimate grade of
a but there are subcategories that we
look at to help determine what that
ultimate score will be and so on the
next slide i'm going to take a bit of a
deeper dive into what those four sub
categories are and how much weight or
importance we put on them okay so you've
seen the block at the top this is the
overall grade you saw in the previous
slide that a that they got but we
realized there are a lot of factors that
determine what makes a good school so
first and foremost we have school
environment this is worth 15 points out
of the total hundred points and the
metrics are a bit different for
elementary and middle school relative to
high school but when it comes to school
environment we're looking at the same
types of things Jen mentioned this
school survey the school environment
survey we want to know from the parents
the teachers the students do they feel
comfortable in their school do they feel
safe do they feel this is a good
environment to be learning in we also
want to look at attendance are they
actually going to this school that they
like so much so that's 15 points that
comes into your score and then 25 points
goes to overall student performance and
as most of you probably know under No
Child Left Behind they're looking at
actual student performance do our
students reach a level of
efficiency on our state tests most
notably in math and English so 25 points
go towards that for the children in
elementary and middle school so children
in grades 3 through 8 and then when we
get to the high school level for
determining high school progress reports
we're looking at these ultimate measures
of success that Jen mentioned earlier so
that's graduation rates and whether
they're really prepared to move on to
what we hope they will move on to which
is a post-secondary institution but here
in New York we really want to emphasize
that it's not just our our students
meeting this bar this level of
proficiency that the state requires us
to report and that's why you see in red
60 points are going towards progress and
that is where this whole name of
progress report really comes in here so
again we are looking at the state test
scores this ela that's English language
arts and math but we're looking at
progress over time are these students
progressing and not just progressing but
progressing past expectations and in the
next slide I'm going to go into a bit
how we determine what each school and
each student should be expected to show
gains in over the course of a year and
then how we determine whether they're
exceeding their expected progress also
just a highlight when it comes to high
school progress reports we don't have
those state test scores but we look at
credit accumulation are these students
on track to graduate on time in those
four years and we also look at whether
they're passing their Regents exams
which is another measure of success for
high school students and then lastly you
see on the right there's another 15
points extra credit all the kids get
extra credit so why shouldn't we so
these are points that can be gained by a
school when they really show exemplary
performance with high needs populations
so there's different populations
throughout the city that notoriously are
harder to serve and so if certain
schools are standing out for serving
these populations really well closing
the achievement gap that has been
present for so long and there's extra
points to gain there and so when you
take that all together it determines the
schools overall grade that you saw in
the previous report
now there are a number of objectives
that the progress report hopes to meet
first is really just to be able to look
at student achievement on a broad scale
so again it's not just test scores we're
incorporating a whole range of
information and we're getting data from
a variety of sources to really bring it
all together and see how are our kids
doing second we want to look at outcomes
not inputs we want to evaluate our
schools based on quantifiable data and
again we want to measure their progress
and performance so we want to measure
what the schools contribute to the
students and not what the students bring
to the school as a school might um you
know have an advantage because they're
just getting a certain type of kid but
that's not enough we want to show that
these schools are really having an
impact on these kids and letting them
move beyond perhaps what we expect their
potential to be and then lastly I want
to talk about this idea of peer and City
comparisons so we really focus in New
York on this idea of peer schools it's
not enough to say that we expect two
middle schools in the Bronx to both
increase X number of degrees in a given
year that's not necessarily fair because
as we know every school has a different
makeup and if you look up on the far
right you see what would happen if we
didn't control for certain factors so on
the x-axis what we're calling the pier
index is the percent of certain
subpopulations in a given school so we
have percent of english-language
learners at that school we have percent
of students who fall under the special
education category we have percent title
1 and percent black and Hispanic
students and as you see they hire the
proportion of these students in your
school the lower average proficiency
that you see so what we have is this
idea of the pier index which controls
for all of these factors and then
factors into your progress report grade
so when we're saying how much are you
progressing over the course of a given
year it's not uverse the city it's not
your school versus all the other schools
even in your district it's you versus
your peer school so the
other schools around you 20 above you 20
below you so every school has a
different peer school group how are you
doing relative to those schools to to
really level that playing field there
okay so that is our first major tool
that we use a major accountability tool
and as you probably gathered a lot of
this is quantitative data that goes into
this progress report we do use the
surveys but we also are quantifying
what's on the surveys from the teachers
and the parents and the students so we
want to acknowledge it's not not all
data is quantitative data you also have
to look at qualitative data so another
big tool we have here is what's known as
the Quality Review and what this is it's
an on-site really in-depth two to three
day review of how our schools are doing
so we have evaluator go into the schools
meet with the administrators meet with
people at the school and see how is this
school really functioning and then we
take all of the data that's gathered and
I'll show you an example of a rubric on
the next page of the different items we
evaluate on but we take all that
information and give it back to the
school and a really well laid out report
what are you doing well where are your
areas for improvement and making that
data available throughout the city so
everyone really is being held
accountable and just like on the
progress report you had an a b c d or f
for the quality review you can score as
well developed proficient development
developing or underdeveloped ok so this
next slide is it's pretty busy as you
can see i hope you can see it in the
back but it's an example of the the
rubric and the fundamentals that the
quality review is really based on so a
person doesn't go around the school
checking off this one rubric there are a
lot of subcategories but these are
really the core features of the quality
review so the people who go into the
school and who are evaluating the school
are looking at the instructional and
organizational coherence of the school
and they're seeing how well the school
is doing it gathering and
analyzing their own schools data and
we'll show you that a bit later on how
schools can do that especially through
the use of eros which gen mentioned how
well are these schools planning and
setting goals for their students and for
their school as a whole how well are
they aligning capacity building and how
well are they able to monitor the
progress of their school what's going on
in their school and then revise
accordingly if they see that things
aren't going well how are they revising
that to make sure it starts to go well
ok and then jens just you're going to
jump in here and explain to you now that
we have all these tools we have all
these measures we graded the schools
what do we do with these numbers ok so
here's where the second E comes in
within enforce and here is where the
consequences are when when schools are
not being successful for multiple years
they do face consequences and in those
cases there can be phase out decisions
and when we're thinking about a
phase-out many many people may refer to
that distinctly as a closure as a school
closure we're looking at at this as the
school has not been successful with its
students for multiple years and now we
need to take steps to replace that
school and what we will do is begin to
phase out to school grade by grade and
allow the students who in particular in
the high schools allow those students to
finish to finish at that phase out
school but we're going to part of our
strategy and again that was next door
also is about how do we build new small
schools that can really work with
students on a very day-to-day very
frequent basis and be really give that
one-on-one that one-on-one attention
that our students need so when we're
looking what is what triggers a school
to be acknowledged as being a possible
school that we would want to identify
for phase out and that would be both our
progress report if we see schools that
are D and an F or
schools that have many consecutive years
of being a sea we will begin to flag
those as trigger triggering as schools
that we need to now now watch more
carefully or recommend that foreclosure
other things that we look at our the
quality review if if a school has a has
an under koala has an under
underperforming score we will look at
that as well and finally New York State
also releases those schools that are
persistently low achieving and those are
the bottom five percent of schools in
all of New York State those are
identified and those can be potential
schools for the phase-out process as
well as high schools with a graduation
rates below sixty percent for three
years in a row and if we look at that
continuum if we go back to that first or
second slide where we looked at those
graduation rates those are well below
the citywide average of nearly 65 68%
where we are now other factors so we
don't just do this arbitrarily and on
one data point we take multiple data
points into consideration we look at we
look at school performance over time so
again it's not just you you didn't have
successes past year where we're going to
phase you add immediately we look at
multiple years and multiple multiple
progress indicators to see if if if it
was you know some sort of extenuating
circumstance for this one for this one
year we look at four high schools in
particular we look at demand our
students want to attend this school if
school if if if all of these factors we
see the school is underperforming and
students we see are not wanting to apply
to that school and we can't enroll
students that is a key factor for us
right supply and demand it's very
important that's why we provide choice
to our students there could be other
structural factors that are taken into
account when we're looking at this kind
of decision for instance how many years
of principal has
in there the school size and any
particular concentrations of a of a
school population finally we look at
what are the replacement options for
this school is it a viable is it is it
viable for us to consider that to be a
phase out of phase out campus or phase
out school and finally we do this with
multiple multiple groups and
stakeholders really looking very
carefully at these decisions including
both and ultimately the Chancellor you
see him you see him and soon to be her
at the bottom of the screen as one of
the final decision makers here but we
also go to the community we we meet with
them we meet with them early and
continuously to talk about this process
to to get them strapped around it
because schools personal education is
personal and these are hard decisions
and you know for for for a school and
community to think through we work with
the community superintendents and the
networks to to really help the community
think through this process but now let's
go to the more positive work that we do
well lighten it up a little bit and but
all of these things are important for us
to be able to be very transparent with
the information but most importantly
these things can exist unless we enable
schools to actually work through these
issues so part of our pillar around an
accountability is also inquiry and we
have really built to establish
collaborative inquiry in the schools and
provide a real team teaching approach so
we thought we would I'm going to jump
back to Katie she's going to talk a
little bit about that and then showcase
some of the other tools okay so as Jen
mentioned we don't really want to get to
the point where we're considering
phase-out we want to use these tools I
talked about before to help our teachers
and administrators make really smart
decisions about their students to help
move them forward so we have these
collaborative inquiry teams throughout
the school system and going to go
through the four main pieces of
collaborative inquiry and then the next
slide is really going to show you how
this is a cyclical process and how it's
just it's really on going and how it can
really help so collaborative inquiry
it's really focused on student outcomes
using a systematic data approach so the
thing we really need to do here is teach
our teachers how to use student data to
drive their decision-making and then
when we show you the tools namely eros
it's going to really give you a better
sense of what we're giving two teachers
and saying here here's how you can use
your student data now now do something
with it and we'll help you along the way
figure out what to do with it and how to
make decisions based on what you're
seeing because not necessarily is it the
case that every teacher in our entire
school system is going to know what to
do with a whole host of quantitative
data we're talking about student test
scores on the state tests but also on
individual class level and all different
factors so we have teams of teachers get
together and focus on how to handle
students who are struggling what they
can do but they're really doing this in
a team environment so no one is alone in
this process they're all sharing the
different things they've learned along
the way with one another and we're
really trying to develop and deepen
really rigorous research based
instruction and we're trying to also
distribute leadership so again it's not
you're not just one teacher in one
classroom in once you know one school
throughout this city there are so many
students here people need to really all
be in this together so this next slide
is showing you what I mean by a cyclical
approach and if you want to pick a
starting point in this circle I guess
perhaps the best place to start because
of what I've been talking about is
examining student work and data so
looking at the data and trying to get it
into a format that is best suitable for
doing something with it for figuring out
patterns in the data figuring out who's
struggling have I seen a pattern in
who's struggling what were they doing
last year relative to this year how can
I help but it's also examining teacher
work so what am i doing and how
and I connect that to what my students
are learning and perhaps what I think
you know maybe what I come up with as a
great lesson for how to teach the area
of a triangle I think it's really great
but then I'm able to look at my student
data and I see only a third of the class
was able to pass my quiz on that so you
know can I put those two data pieces
together and say what now and that
brings us to the next stage in the
circle engaging external resources so a
lot of these tools like the different
versions of Eros are there to help our
teachers so they can go in to Eros and
say you know get anyone else have an
idea for how to teach area of a triangle
that I might not have tried before and
did it work for them maybe I'll try that
next time and incorporate that so that
goes along with defining instructional
strategies setting goals so maybe they
say you know neck by the end of the
semester I want to make sure that a
hundred percent of my kids can define
the area of a triangle so they're
setting targeted goals just like we set
targeted goals throughout the city again
this flows into the next which is taking
action to implement instructional
strategy really using the tools we
provide them you know using that new
piece of pd you found on eros testing it
out and then going back to your data
your student data and saying well did it
work down now what percentage of my
students are able to figure this out and
if it did work not just keeping that to
yourself I mean that's part of this
whole thing of working in a team going
back and sharing that with others so
maybe you use that one lesson that you
got from Aris that one tool about how to
teach the area of a triangle but you
tweaked it a bit you wanted to put your
own spin on it and you found that that
really worked well then you'll go back
and you will share that with others so
the next teacher that come along who's
having trouble with that he or she can
use what you've learned over time to
really help hone their skills so it's
really our hope that we can provide our
teachers with not just the tools like
the progress report but also a system
that really brings teachers throughout
the city together teachers who may not
ever physically see one another a lot of
these are professional development
sessions that are
line or web-based tools but really
trying to you know highlight this idea
of working in collaboration with one
another hence the term collaborative
inquiry and jen's going to highlight on
some of the fun features of this next
tool this eres tool it's just a data
snapshot there's a whole lot behind it
and we definitely encourage you to go
and take a deeper look on our website on
the various pieces of Eros so for those
of you who've worked in schools are in
classrooms one of the biggest complaints
that teachers have is that they don't
have all of the data in front of them to
help drive instruction so the screenshot
that we see here and I think you have
jump drives of of our presentation so
that you could probably see it a little
bit a little bit better because it looks
a little blurred from here here's an
example of a class roster that a teacher
could log in and what they would have
are the students names it would identify
whether they had an IEP or any other
learning learning me that they would
have and then next to it would be their
attendance and their their their
year-to-date attendance plus also plus
also what was their attendance last year
so that you have both historical
information as well as current
information and its color coded in a way
that helps teachers identify where there
may be areas of concern then as you go
further you have the assessment results
and this this here is just the
assessment results the absolute
performance of the students but we do
have other screens where you can dive in
deeper and get to more granular
information around the state test
results next to that are the next few
columns just on this one screen our
students performance on their diagnostic
or formative assessments so you see how
it's really all very well laid out on
that page and that's just again one
little snapshot of the broader era
system other things that that a teacher
can do with this and we also have the
counterpart i should say is called eras
parents link and the parents can look at
this information to parents are provided
with a login information
and they too can see all of their
students information again being
accountable for the results you need to
understand and and see those results in
order to take action so in on this
platform in addition to teachers being
able to view all of their students
information plus contact information
they can examine the student data and
charts and graphs or you know how you
like the data is how you can get the
data kind of thing you can there are
other platforms with in areas where you
can engage in the inquiry with folks
outside of your school within your
school you're going to use this and
you're going to be poring over the data
and your team teaching approach but then
you can collaborate outside you're
outside the classroom and outside the
school and also share resources you can
upload lesson plans and and materials
and best practices that you found
through this system in order remember we
have 1500 schools in New York City so so
we'd have to Yankee Stadium actually
wouldn't be large enough I'm not sure a
giant stadium or is it jet stadium for
me it's jet stadium would wouldn't be
large enough either to accommodate all
of these groups and people and and
Corinne must be a giant fan because
she's she's grinning at me so what's
happen next let's finish on that so this
way we can open it up to some question
and answers from the group so okay so
there's a little graphic that I forgot
about so the first thing as many of you
may have been heard about the Common
Core State Standards new york state has
adopted the Common Core State Standards
those will be the national standards
moving forward and right now we're in a
process of building capacity around
understanding what those standards look
like we currently have the new york
state standards in order for us to get
to a place where our teachers have
internalized the Common Core State
Standards we have a lot of work to do
New York's some folks who are familiar
with them are shaking their heads the
common core state standards are really
it's really k-16 it's not k12 it's
really a bench
mark in order for our students to be
prepared for college and career
readiness New York state is going to be
changing their state test to align with
those common core state test standards
and they're going to begin sprinkling
that in that those standards into
assessments in 11 school year 2011 2012
and it will be completely operational
these new tests aligned to the Common
Core State Standards in 2014 2015 so we
have a lot of work to do along the way
but I assure you it's going to be a
bumpy road and again the goals of these
new assessments are really for students
to be able to synthesize analyze
evaluate information in a much more
higher order higher-order way than where
our state standards have typically ended
this really brings that to the next
level and they will the new assessments
when they are completed our to really
allow for accountability accountability
to decisions to be made across a broad
spectrum including teachers schools and
students and obviously that will improve
our teaching and learning and prepare
our students for college and careers
just to move forward many of you have
heard about the race to the top race to
the top grant competition by the United
States Department of Education New York
State was one of the finalists or
actually one of the winners and we look
forward to receiving a 240 240 million
almost 250 million dollars within race
to the top and that is really to build
the capacity of our schools teachers and
principals and our students in order to
meet the challenges that face us as we
implement Common Core State Standards
and that will also encounter ours is a
great system now we are we need to make
sure that all of our schools across New
York State have those kinds of data
systems to support their work and so
some money will be spent there and on
teacher evaluation is a primary goal of
race to the top to bring in a fair and
accurate assessment of our teachers okay
and finally what we are doing this year
in order to help 2014-2015 sounds like a
long time away but there is a 1500
schools eighty eighty thousand teachers
1.1 million students we have a lot of
work to do in order to phase in this
process this year we have already
trained superintendents Network teams
and are now training teachers and
principals on really how do we how do we
build that capacity how do we what what
are the common core state standards what
do they mean and what do they mean to
our teaching and learning in our schools
what kinds of practices do we need to
change and most importantly the thing
that we need to do now and start to
really look look toward is how are we
how are we building capacity so that our
students are not needing in need of
remediation when they enter secondary or
I'm sorry post-secondary college and
careers and one interesting thing that
we've done is we have a data sharing
agreement with with the City University
for the past year and a half all too
often our data or k12 data goes to the
universities but we never know what
happens so we consider our memorandum of
agreement with with CUNY as landmark
because now what we're getting is
information back on our students and not
just whether they enrolled or whether
they persisted or graduated but what
courses did they take how did they do on
those courses what was their GPA and now
we can think about what are the
predictors of success in college it's
amazing it's amazing and exciting work
and so hopefully when the next summit
comes around we'll be able to share so
much of those findings with you so with
that I think I'll turn it over to Jeff
that was a lot to digest I want to open
it up to questions please if you have a
question come to the mics because
although we probably hear you this is
being recorded and I appreciate it if
primarily we focus on questions but
since many of you are coming from other
systems and maybe approaching some of
these issues differently I think we are
interested in hearing also something
about your experience as long as you
know as I don't get impatient if you're
going on too long I'll start squirming
and send you a signal that way all right
hi thank you so much for the very
thorough presentation on the
accountability system in New York City
I'm from Rio as his half out body until
we work with the Department of Education
for the city of Rio and we were just
wondering about this last thing you
mentioned in passing of advancing on
teacher evaluation and a fair and
accurate way of assessing and evaluating
whether a teacher is effective or not so
I'm wonder if you could give us some
more information on where you're going
with that and what would qualify as a
fair and effective way of evaluating
teachers so so as you know that's a hot
topic in New York City about teacher
evaluation for those who may not be
aware um it's it's what teacher
evaluation is a much-debated a national
conversation that's going on is how to
evaluate teachers accurately and
effectively we currently right now use a
value-added approach for our teachers
and grades four through eight who have
multiple years of data to make judgments
using English language arts and math
scores however we are participating in a
national study with the gates foundation
to to understand what are the measures
of effective teaching and what other
information we can bring to bear to
understand this this more holistically
this approach and that's also part of
the race to the top dollars is to build
an evaluation system that can support
that can support and build on the work
that we've done around the value-added
models there's a
a good study that came out yesterday
from the Brookings Institute about about
the value of value-added metrics but
also what else you need to make a
well-rounded system hi my name is Roy
I'm from Jerusalem we have a system
fairly similar in a way we have a
dashboard well we are students of Joel
Klein for a few years so we have the
chance of doing that part of our
discussion in Jerusalem is what is
usually measured is what's fairly easy
to measure and that's graduation results
and results of national tests and that
is easy fairly easy to measure we have
the results and we track the numbers but
as we learned in the morning education
is not only about graduation from high
school it's about capacity building it's
about believing in yourself it's about
and a variety of values that you want if
you want a good citizen to come out of
high school it's not only that he has
graduated math and English and science
and so the main discussion we have with
principals and teachers is that they are
saying look you track us for results of
graduations which is okay and we know
that we can improve and sometimes in bed
ways for example letting go the week
students and then our results would be
great because we were letting them go so
do you have this and part of what
we are trying to do now is asking what
can we measure beside graduation because
otherwise we are tilting the well you're
saying education is about graduation and
if you want principles to teach capacity
building values and other important
stuff beside knowledge transfer
transformation then how can you measure
that and do you have any thoughts on the
matter so um that also is something that
we were on a panel last week where we
even Jeff for you at the retrospective
at the panel presentation so where we
where that was debated also where if you
at our elementary and middle school
progress report it is quite a bit waited
on the English language arts and
mathematics scores one way too and we
understand there is science and social
studies are very important the arts and
how do we bring those into our
accountability system part of the
difficulty in that is that we don't have
annual assessments from from the state
um longitudinally so we have a fourth
grade science test and we have an 8th
grade science test we really are we
really want to measure the progress of
students in order to measure the
progress of students from year to year
we need a year to your assessment but
but we really want to think about how do
we broaden broaden the spectrum that's
why we do have the survey the school
survey becomes an important an important
factor it's 15 points of the overall
progress report grade because we know
that school climate the expectations
that the adults in the building have for
their students is very important and
becomes a factor in student achievement
at the school so we use that as one of
the broadening factors also the quality
reviews are another way that we can get
to what's happening at the school what
is a school doing so it's not just an
absolute outcome whether that's a
progress or performance measure at the
high school level we actually have it's
a little more well-rounded because we
can look at credit accumulation from
year to year of students and when we're
looking at the examinations we can look
at we can look at a multitude of the
examinations not just English and maths
but all of the graduation requirements
which are in five subject areas again
with the survey and with a quality
review but but we are always looking to
explore and open open that up one thing
that we are adding and it was announced
yesterday we're going to be adding
college readiness indicators on the on
the high school report cards so that we
can look at how are our schools
preparing those students for for college
and careers
Thank You Kelly burling from Pearson is
this one on two um I have a couple
questions so I'll try it to be fast the
first is the survey you discussed is
that internally created somewhere in the
city department of education and what
sort of correlates do you see between
survey results and test score results in
your other growth measures if any and
then also what are your growth measures
you said compared to median growth is
this a cohort that you're looking at are
you just looking at the increase in
percentage of kids proficient per year
what was that growth measure that you're
using sure so um now it lost the first
question because I was focused on the
same oh the survey got it ok so the
surveys were initially done by an
outside company but now we have for the
most part brought those indicators in
house but we created the survey both
with educators and researchers across
the city and across the country to help
inform the questions and the pieces we
looked at the university of chicago in
particular who who had already a similar
a similar survey implemented but they
again sample and we wanted to make sure
that everybody had the opportunity to
respond from from families and also we
have teachers responding to when we look
at the correlates the school those
things do correlate with our indicators
of progress and such one thing that we
would like to look at which we would
want to think about is does that change
over time depending on the status of
your school and i think that that's
something that we want to explore going
forward and we're also looking at
different studies about whether or not
we can build a real climate index out of
and i think that's where you are going
for out of out of the survey measures
right and then on i think we want to
just talk about our proficiency ratings
Katie do you want to answer that a
little bit sure
so I'm not sure if this one hundred
percent answers your question but in
terms of what our outcome measures are
it really focuses around this idea of
the pier index and making sure that we
are only comparing our schools any given
school to the schools that are really in
its peer group and so this will change
from year at here it'll change school to
school there is no one school that has
the same exact peer group as the other
because purposefully we make sure that
that schools scores are the median for
their peer group at the starting point
and then we're able to track how they're
doing relative to the rest of the
schools in their group both the 20
schools that are above them and the 20
schools that are below them at their
base line in the baseline of course
changes from year to year I think I
think part of the question was also
whether it's scale scores or proficiency
levels they are they are we call them
proficiency um I'm well so I don't know
how familiar everyone is with this but
when we talk about whether a student
meets proficiency on our state test
scores that's do they reach a level
three so there's level 1 level 2 level 3
and level 4 and that's the ultimate cut
off however we like to take that a step
further because grouping our students
our million students into four buckets
doesn't necessarily seem the you know
the most straightforward way to do
things so we have a range ranging from
one to four point five on a hundredth of
a point scale and so a student in any
given class could get if he or she is a
two she could be a two point zero one or
two point nine nine and so when we're
developing what our peer schools are
it's not just what proportion of
students in that school are reaching
proficient meaning reaching a level 3 or
higher we look at their exact average
peer proficiency index rating so a
school might have an average of two
point six seven 3.45 but that's
basically a transformation from our
scale scores that's where I got tripped
up on my words
so it's a test are made up of scale
scores and performance levels and scale
scores almost feel like for those of you
researchers in the room standard score
standard scores kind of feel like that
awful black box that nobody understands
and how does it work so what we did is
we transform those scale scores into
proficiency ratings which just really
said your level one you could be a level
one point one the level 1 point 2 etc so
it just made made them more real but it
translates to the scale scores and then
we look at the students for this year
and we looked at their percentile rank
among all of the scale score so we could
look at movement from year to year and
that enabled us to stabilize stabilize
the system because there was a lot of
movement around the state tests so if we
saw the percentile rank from one year
compared to the percentile rank of the
next year of a student we could we could
normalize some of the bounce in the test
scores that we were seeing I'm Robert
for hammer from the city of Antwerp
Belgium I was wondering if I understood
well you're measuring your graduation
scores on time this means that you put a
lot of emphasis on the on time now in
Antwerp for us the prior main priority
is graduation we we try we cope with a
lot of immigrant students and we have a
problem of a certain percentage it's up
to 15 percentage that don't graduate
high school so we try to diminish this
percentage or too hard to increase the
percentage of that have a graduation but
we don't regard in the first place if
it's on time because a lot of these
students start with a different starting
point with the different capacities and
so and I wonder whether you take this
into account well we couldn't agree more
if I could just respond
to that in particular for our English
language learners the the next important
marker after we see the four-year
outcome is to see how many of those
students are still enrolled because our
fifth and sixth year rates which we also
track carefully and follow we know are
so important because it's even more
important that these students are
staying in school and persisting up
through when they went at 21 is when
they eventually aged out of the of the
school system but the under No Child
Left Behind they are wanting to also
extend the the accountability so that we
look at fifth and sixth year fifth and
six year rates because we acknowledge
that that's a critically important
especially for our special needs
populations and I have a second question
you will excuse me but it's about a face
out of schools I have two questions
first is how long does it take to phase
out of school once you're going through
and second is you replace it I
frequently hear that you replace it by
smaller schools don't you have a
capacity problem not yet Anthony Anthony
a chair it's very interesting to replace
it by a new school and drastic but it's
very efficient i think but to replace it
by a smaller school it's kind of a
structural approach but in in my city
where we're struggling with a capacity
problem for all schools we need to build
new schools new schools and so so so i
think one thing that we should talk
about is that when we are opening and
closing schools we're not really talking
about brick and mortar so we're not
building uh you know we're not building
something here and then you know taking
down a building what in New York City
what existed in many
of in other places as well is that our
schools were rather large and they were
upwards of 1,500 students and sometimes
2,000 3,000 students in many of those
cases those are very very large
buildings so the schools when we go to
do a phase out and I'll get you a
question about how that phase out works
we're able to to begin a school where
one large one once once belonged what
we're doing is able to have a school
smaller schools coexist and there was a
very large national study done on our on
our small school movement from MDRC that
really showed the the success of these
first cohorts of our small schools and I
would invite you to take a look at that
but that's how that's how that works so
we're actually not oh not not physically
building something but really working
and breaking up a often times larger
schools in too many more into smaller
schools within that building that can
coexist and just like any family
sometimes the coexistence works better
than others but we have worked through
ways to enable those schools to be
successful and share and share many of
the resources within that school around
the phase-out once it's decided as a
community that that the end by the
Chancellor that the school will indeed
be phased out what that means is that
the school no longer take incoming
students into that school and phasing
out means that they will allow allow
those students who are still in the
building to finish up until their grade
level is no longer it's usually
typically in the high schools where
where I can use the best example where
we have a nine through twelve ninth
grade through twelfth grade school and
so once it's decided that that school
will indeed phase out they won't take
any more ninth graders so now there'll
be a 10th 11th and 12th grade the
following year they'll be in eleventh
and twelfth grade then there'll be a
twelfth grade and
then until they are completely phased
out so it's a multi-pronged approach
similarly that's how we phase in our new
small schools we first take an incoming
ninth grade then it goes 10th grade and
that helps to build a capacity of that
new smaller school as well oh come this
will be our last question comment I mean
I'm actually in a new school in a phase
out my school my phase out closed down
two years ago for failure because the
progress report was consistently addy
your time and time again and the
learning environment survey was very low
the parents were not happy with what was
going on in the school so I proposed a
new school and we are it was AK 28
school in the Rockaways that was closed
down and I'm the elementary school and
right now last year we started pre-k to
third there was also a new middle school
that went in and started with just grade
six this year were pre-k and the
phase-out was 457 eight this year I'm
pre-k to for the new middle school six
and seven and the phase-out this is the
final year it's five and eight and then
next year it'll just be the two schools
coexisting we have we work together all
three principles we share the divide the
space up we have common space time it's
a really it's for us it's working really
well we have a very good building
council where all the three principles
work together and you know we are doing
really well so if anyone wants to come
visit our school invitations open it's a
really beautiful place to visit so thank
you so I want to ask you all to thank
our panel that'll be the end of today
you